you know while I was setting up for this
podcast I was looking at some numbers
around how men handle uh you know
loneliness and stuff and it's like you
know some of the stuff I talked about in
my book as well too you know the the
incarceration rate for men is much
higher than women for the exact same
crime in fact women get off much more
than you know men do obviously um and
you know things like um guys selfing
themselves uh like to use the phrase
taking permanent steps to a temporary
problem in their life and men are three
times more likely to do this than women
men are 10 times more likely to do this
than women in a
divorce guys generally suffer in a lot
of
Silence
so if you know somebody right now and
you probably do colleag cooworker friend
from the gym guy from the dojo maybe a
guy you ride bikes with whatever your
hobbies or interests happen to be family
member cousin whoever it happens to be
you probably know somebody right now
that's going through a divorce or
dealing with some difficulties in his
relationship give him a call shoot him a
text shoot him a text hey man I just
wanted to check in you know how's things
going I know [__] tough for the whole
breakup or the untying of the KN or
whatever happens to be just do a
check-in you know being interested and
being interest in is part of forming
human connections and again this is
going from somebody that's an introvert
I would also get very very
clear
on what it is that you're looking for
from a friend from a woman job it
doesn't matter what it is in life guys
get clear on what it is that you're
looking
for get very very clear on what it is
that you're looking for and only allow
those people I would I would rather be
by myself than than than to surround
myself with shitty people shitty friends
shitty women any of those things I I
just don't have maybe it's because I've
gotten older and I just don't give a
[__] anymore right but I think you know
when you're younger you tend to make
more concessions it's like ah I've been
friends with you know Mike since high
school so what if you know somebody
caught him jerking off in a plant or
something like that right you go of make
up these like weird excuses you know
head you're going to get out of life
what you tolerate right you're going to
tolerate mediocre people if you're the
smartest guy in the room you're in the
wrong room you I've said this many times
say it again put yourself in rooms where
you're not the smartest guy in room put
yourself in events or extracurriculars
or sporting you know gigs where you're
not the best you're not the smartest
you're not the most
competent especially if you want to
learn and you want to network you don't
want to be lonely I've never felt lonely
the dojo in any of the classes and like
legit I went there probably thousand
thousands of times right over the four
and four odd years that I was uh you
know training doing crb doing boxing Ki
all that sort of stuff and there was
almost always somebody new hey Rich how
you doing nice to meet you all right you
know because they would always pair you
off and you'd have to go and do do some
exercise very very easy to you know make
contacts and open the doors when you get
out of your own head in your own house
but if you're sitting there on your
screens watching TV shows or sports
playing video games and all that you
don't allow yourself the
opportunity to go out there and find
interesting people doing interesting
things and being interesting yourself so
again you want to get very very clear on
what you want from a network what you
want from a friendship what you want
from a woman or women whatever that
happens to be and being fastidious about
getting rid of the losers I get mad when
I say get rid of losers hey I'm not I'm
I'm not even going to apologize for it
you need to get rid of the losers in
your life you know who they are you
probably have people in your life still
again well I've been friends with so and
so since high
school so what really so what I think
there's maybe two people that I still
talk to from high school and even then
it's very like sporadically and randomly
like we shoot a text to each other
something comes up you know there's a
picture sent hey we should get together
soon blah blah blah but you never really
do because you live so far apart but
these guys are cool right like I keep in
touch with them because they're
successful and we did awesome stuff when
we were younger and we're doing awesome
stuff today in our own Realms in our own
you know world world sort of
thing but it's okay you know let people
go that are mediocre let them go just
you don't have to make an announcement
hey we're not going to be friends
anymore just don't respond to them right
lose their phone number so get clear on
what you want from your friends get
clear on what you want from the network
get clear on what you want from a woman
or women whatever that happens to
be I can't emphasize this enough guys
stay away from sh people I really
can't you need to create a vacuum okay
whatever it is that you're filling your
time with that's making you feel lonely
you need to create a vacuum so that it
can fill with something else vacuums
fill by osmosis right you spend if you
take 24 hours in a day let's say you
take eight to nine of them sleeping you
take eight of them working
you take an hour or two commuting doing
miscellaneous things grabbing a bite to
eat uh you know picking up some grocery
stuff like that what are you doing with
that left over time the extra few hours
that you've got left in your day right
because if you're pissed off about being
lonely or feeling lonely or feeling
alone and you're spending your like I
can tell you exactly what your problem
is by what you're doing with your spare
time you spent it watching sports what
do you expect go play sports join a
co-ed you know Sports League murder ball
ball hockey volleyball whatever it
happens to be anything right I've done
all of these things they're great
exercise they're great way to network
there's always a hey let's grab a beer
or a drink or some wings after this sort
of thing there's usually women involved
you know just do a co-ed one um and
because you know it's it's athletic
they're generally fit and reasonably
attractive you know for the most
part you know so trade watching sports
for playing sport you like video games
you like playing video games okay fine
maybe a little bit of them but all the
time I remember I was at a hospital once
and um I was SK and I [__] up my leg I
thought it was broken or could have been
uh shattered you know the shin or
whatever so I go to the [__] hospital
I'm sitting there waiting for 2 three
hours four hours go by just you know
there's all these moms coming in with
their 2-year-old with a [__] dot on
their back and a s and they think
they're going to die so in Canada
Healthcare is free you know mostly free
anyway not great but mostly free so I'm
sitting there for three or four hours in
a merge with what I think is a broken
leg and they put me into the room B and
sitting beside me in the next room with
a curtain so you can hear everything so
the doctor goes to that kid first
because he was there before me all right
so why you're here today what's wrong I
can't feel my knees do what do you mean
you can't feel your knees well I was
sitting there playing a Warcraft raid
for 12 hours and my legs I just can't
feel them I don't know what's wrong with
them the feeling hasn't come back and
she's like [__] move buddy move your
legs move your body they've gone numb
because you're sitting your ass in a
chair doing nothing playing video games
for 12 hours why you wasting my time
that's not what she said but I could
that's what I'm thinking and I could
tell by the tone of her voice she was
probably thinking the exact same thing
but this is what happens right you get
caught up in these
Worlds the online worlds you know the
metaverses of the you know the world
today you get all caught up in it
leveling up your character oh if I play
one more raid then I can get that armor
that I want and I'll get 37 gold pieces
so I can get this special item and it'll
improve my stamina by plus three points
and minimize my defenses by this amount
and we and we start calculating all the
[__] trust me I know because I used to
play you know these geeky games all the
time too and then you're like leveling
up a character to the best it can
possibly be in a video game you got this
Dragon blow your whistle and the dragon
comes flying over and you can do all
this cool [__] on it you're a you're a
wizard Warrior whatever it is you want
in that video game world but in real
life you're down here level up your real
life
character spend the same amount of time
effort resources leveling up your real
life character right increase the amount
of money that you make increase your
phys physical conditioning increase your
competency skills in combat these are
all things that are useful having a
strong healthy body broad shoulders
narrow waste muscular sort of build you
know you're interesting you're funny
you've got a network you do cool [__]
you ride a motorcycle no you do rallies
Drive nice cars no do you play hockey I
don't care what it is yeah you know if
you're gonna find yourself in a position
to be interested in and be interesting
doing it in a virtual world is not going
to get you what you want in the real
world
and that's just a cold hard truth about
it man I've done both I've done
both I've seen both and a far better of
your time do it for
yourself I would I would probably have a
lot more money today and made a lot
fewer
mistakes and been further ahead had I
not wasted a lot of the time that I had
in Virtual Worlds and virtual
friendships in shitty friendships
keeping shitty friends around keeping
shitty women around um
because it's it just boils down to
raising your standards guys that's all
it is when you set your standards higher
when you when you raise the bar for
yourself when you raise those standards
higher for you the outcome in your life
dividends paid are just exponential
they're off the freaking
chart you don't have to be lonely or
alone or those
things there's there's lots and lots of
really really good men out there that
are good at being men that you can form
friendships and bonds with look the
reason why I created my own Community
you know through the channel work that I
do is because people were always saying
hey let me introduce you to this I've
got this I've got that I'd like to hang
out with you let's talk about this and
you know I'll tell you something the
guys that I've paid attention to and the
guys that I've become friends with that
are into integrated in my community that
are that are invaluable at this point
are the guys that are interesting that
I'm also interested in and we do cool
[__] together and I mean the stuff that
I've posted on social media like
anywhere out there that you might have
seen that's just the tip of the iceberg
like that's just a highlight real you
know the kinds of stuff that we hang out
and do is just phenomenal it's the same
thing with women too right decide what
you want you want multiple women in your
life do you want a woman in your life
you want no women in your life you want
to deal with on a short-term basis or
arms length basis dating only you know
whatever is you want to
call there's there's there's still lots
of good women out there they're not all
obese purple-haired disagreeable angry
mean um manh haters they're
not there's a lot of those ones out
there but you don't have to spend time
with them you get to decide who you
spend time with you get to decide who
you invite into your life you get to
decide who you hang out with with and
making concessions by having lower
standards is going to get you to [__]
just going to get you nasty [__] I
really hope you guys enjoyed that clip
if you want to watch the full length
podcast you can find that over here that
clip's from if you're new to the channel
make sure you hit subscribe over here
and pin down below in the top comment
you'll find a bunch of useful links to
my website my supplement line books and
a bunch of other stuff have an amazing
day peace out